[Music]
what did obama know
about ufos
a new government report is keeping the
unidentified
and unidentified flying object u.s intel
officials say they found no
evidence that the weird things navy
fighter pilots have been seeing recently
are alien
spacecraft but they say they can't rule
it out
either a way to take a stand intel guy
on video the strange objects moved in
ways that defied logic
then plummeted at 40 000 miles per hour
sounds like cnn's ratings
am i right tom meanwhile former
president barack obama was recently
asked about the subject on the
notion of aliens were proven to be real
he asserted
there would be immediate arguments like
well we need to spend a lot more money
on weapon systems to defend ourselves
new religions would pop up and who knows
what kind of arguments we get into
interesting officials said none of the
120 incidents they examined were the
work of the u.s military
although they haven't ruled out
technology experiments from russia or
china
well that's comforting but if china says
they aren't responsible
their word is good enough for me
cat you've tried to get abducted and
they declined
uh so they might they they are fairly
astute about quality human life
um i i'm actually a quality human
and if i'm not that's actually a huge
reflection on your judgment
so i i see i i think that the ufo thing
i think it's a thing yeah yeah i think i
think their aliens
are probably out there maybe because why
wouldn't there be
you know and if the government says uh
maybe maybe not they don't know what
they're talking
about how would they know they couldn't
even figure out a virus
they thought a virus came from a
pangolin exactly and of course we're you
know
that would that be weird like we're
weird like we kind of suck like freaks
and geeks was canceled after one season
because it couldn't compete with who
wants to be a millionaire
right like they're probably out there
and they just they don't want to hang
out with us
still defending james franco not at all
not at all i was too old for him 10
years ago
perfect you know so uh joe i want to
throw out my uh reoccurring
uh theory that if uh if there happens to
be alien life forms and they're
delicious and nutritious
it is our responsibility to harvest and
eat them
because we already eat our fellow
earthlings we eat cows and chickens and
lambs
they are earthlings but if all of a
sudden there's something out there
and who cares if they have an iq of 200
if they're delicious
it's on us to eat them that is my theory
i think it is the
i think that like i would go to war over
this theory joe joe i don't know why i'm
talking i don't even know why i'm still
talking
have you have been abducted greg if
aliens think i'm representative of the
human race
joke's on them but i i would eat a half
burger i think you might be onto
something
burger but i i question if they don't
know what it is how can they possibly
say what it isn't
uh it's also interesting to me that like
one day we're reading
fauci's email saying don't offend china
and the next day our government's saying
uh that alien might just be a chinese
technology spying off it goes
[Laughter]
do you think this this idea or that just
ufos is a distraction
from other things like they're you i
think they're distracting you from the
robots
yeah that's what i think i think that
they have thrown you off the scent
of the robot so when the robot invasion
starts you are not going to be prepared
you know it's true because i probably
would have done something on robots
tonight
exactly if it wasn't for the for the uh
space aliens
exactly but this is this is such a my
husband kind of thing
and it i would think that once once they
come out and they like
we think we have aliens you would think
that that would be like oh let me go and
find out
about the aliens and he's like no let me
watch the aliens on the history channel
they literally just said they're they
they're giving you actual
footage of things that they don't know
what it is and you're like
hey back in the 13th century you know
that disc might have been an
alien like you're looking at that
instead so it goes to show you like
we thought we were going to be so
excited if you think back to like the
area 51 yeah when they was going to open
it up and everybody was like oh we're
going to go down there we're going to
see the aliens
now they're telling you the aliens are
here and no one is blinking an eye
you know what though i figured it out
that it has to do with robots
okay so you figured it out just so
when you see these unidentified flying
objects those are like tears
blips in the simulation the simulation
that is created by ai robots
we're just a simulation run by ai robots
and we notice their little holes in the
movie screen those are the holes
tom like the holes in your very soul
that i can see
i can see your holes tom i get it i
understand
but the this shows you how
little i trust the government at this
point yes i've never
been into aliens never believe in
spacemen i never liked the x-files
and then yesterday the government came
out with a statement they said none of
these incidents
show that there's any alien i was like
aliens are here
they're here yeah so you know i believe
just the opposite but
i think that i've never believed in them
really
but my working idea is that if aliens do
exist they're jerks and we should just
shoot them
uh just shoot these things out of the
sky wait can we
make a trade can we can we give a few
earthlings
up and maybe get some get get a quality
train going
i would definitely do because i got a
long list of people i'll take a couple
aliens over some of the ones we got here
now
the entire democratic party you know
what i'm saying
nice red meat there guys yeah sure that
piece up huh
but can't they shoot i mean the thing is
just they put out a statement saying
by the way nobody fly your things you
know because we're going to shoot them
down
yeah and then we can see what it is yes
when it's shot down
yeah but what if it's the bubble boy
throwback to a great story from
yesteryear
the bubble boy remember that one was
that what his name is the balloon boy
balloon
boy i ruined that